No hay lugar a dudas: la guerra comercial
es uno de los temas más calientes de la política
internacional.
Aquí en VisualPolitik, ya os hemos hablado
en varios vídeos sobre las consecuencias
que puede tener [que ya está teniendo] esta
guerra comercial.
Sin embargo, nos faltaba una pregunta que
muchos de vosotros nos habéis hecho - especialmente
a través de nuestra página de Patreon - y
que resulta fundamental para analizar toda
esta cuestión.
¿Por qué diantres Estados Unidos tiene un
déficit comercial tan grande? ¿A qué se
debe, cuál es la causa de este gigantesco
déficit que en 2017 superó los 550.000 millones
de dólares? Y lo más importante de todo
¿Cómo de grave es? y ¿Cómo ponerle remedio?
Sí, puede que alguno de vosotros esté pensando…
[pues muy fácil… si hay déficit comercial
es porque Estados Unidos importa más de lo
que exporta, entre otras cosas por la malvada
competencia desleal que ha desindustrializado
el país. Ergo si castigamos las importaciones
se reducirá el déficit comercial ¿Verdad?
Al fin y al cabo este es el discurso de la
Casa Blanca, del Presidente Trump.]
Pues, amigos, esperad un momento… porque
las cosas no son ni de lejos tan fáciles.
Atentos.
(LA ECUACIÓN FÁCIL)
Escoger, magnificar y denunciar un problema;
poner sobre la mesa un gran número que todos
podamos visualizar; crear y culpar a un enemigo
[que sea o no cierto… eso da igual]; alertar
de las consecuencias y, por último, terminar
con un remedio tan simple y electoralista….
como falso.
Amigos, estas son las claves para crear un
discurso político populista… un discurso
que a la hora de la verdad tal vez no sirve de
nada… pero que te puede permitir ganar elecciones.
(Pues bien, esto es exactamente lo que están
haciendo en la Casa Blanca.
Con el objetivo de ganar votos, han creado
un discurso político que por así decirlo
se sustenta fundamentalmente en una ecuación
con 3 elementos:)
[Y tranquilos que esto no va de matemáticas…
o al menos no del todo]
(Primer elemento: el déficit comercial causa
daños terribles;
segundo elemento: todo es culpa de la competencia
desleal del resto de países, especialmente
de China;
y como tercer elemento la amenaza: por culpa
de todas esas malas artes del resto de países,
la industria y el poder de los Estados Unidos
se están viniendo abajo.)
Sin embargo amigos,… una cosa es el discurso
y otra muy diferente la realidad.
Veréis, para magnificar el problema, los
asesores comerciales de Donald Trump alertan
una y otra vez sobre el impacto negativo que
todo este déficit comercial tiene sobre la
economía norteamerica.
Para ello utilizan esta identidad contable
que estáis viendo en pantalla, que es una
de las fórmulas que se utilizan para calcular
el PIB.
De esta forma el PIB es igual al Consumo,
más la inversión, más el gasto público
más las exportaciones menos las importaciones.
[Vamos, de primero de introducción a la economía.]
(El caso es que viéndolo de esta forma parece
que el dichoso déficit comercial ocasiona
un daño enorme a la economía de Estados
Unidos, y, por supuesto, si se reduce esa
diferencia entre las importaciones y las exportaciones,
entonces se incrementaría el PIB.)
[Prosperidad para todos] Fácil, ¿verdad?
Pues… esperad un momento, porque todo esto
supone simplificar tanto las cosas que al
final cualquier parecido con la realidad es
pura coincidencia.
¿Por qué digo esto? Porque las relaciones
con el resto del mundo influyen mucho, pero
que mucho, en el resto de apartados que conforman
el PIB.
Al fin y al cabo cuando un extranjero invierte
en Estados Unidos o cuando las empresas norteamericanas
compran materias primas, bienes de capital
o bienes intermedios el efecto sobre la economía
no es precisamente negativo.
Todo lo contrario, si por ejemplo todos estos
bienes se encarecen por culpa de los aranceles
entonces las empresas pierden competitividad.
De la misma forma, productos de importación
más caros afectarían, también al sector
minorista… de tal forma que al final…
la relación de ese supuesto déficit comercial
con el PIB no es ni mucho menos tan directa
como podría parecernos a simple vista.
(El segundo elemento que utiliza la Casa Blanca
es el de la competencia desleal, especialmente
la de China… Y claro, supuestamente por
culpa de las malas artes de Pekín, el déficit
de bienes y servicios tan solo con China supera
los 300.000 millones de dólares al año.)
Y ahí es cuando Trump piensa… vamos a ver,
si reducimos el déficit comercial con China…
entonces problema solucionado…. Pues, amigos,
en este caso tampoco las cosas son así.
Primero, lo de la competencia desleal es cuando
menos cuestionable.
Se ha culpado mucho a China de manipular su
divisa, pues… lo cierto es que eso ya no
es así.
De hecho… es todo lo contrario. En los últimos
años el yuan chino se ha apreciado bastante
respecto al dólar.
¿Y sabéis qué ha ocurrido con el déficit
comercial con China cuando Pekín ya no ha
devaluado su moneda para exportar más?
Pues… que se ha disparado.
.
¿Cómo es posible?
(Pues, amigos, lo cierto es que en realidad
el déficit comercial de Estados Unidos con
Asia Oriental en bienes manufacturados ha
sido más o menos constante desde mediados
de los años 90.
Lo que ha cambiado es que lo que antes llegaba
de Taiwán o de Japón, entre otros, ahora
llega directamente desde China, que se ha
convertido en el gran centro de ensamblaje…
Y esto es precisamente lo que ha engordado
tanto el déficit comercial de Estados Unidos
con China.)
Y respecto al último punto…. el de la desindustrialización
y pérdida de competitividad por culpa de
la competencia desleal… pues… Tampoco
es cierto.
Las exportaciones de Estados Unidos [que sigue
siendo el segundo mayor exportador del mundo]
se encuentran en niveles récord… lo mismo
que la producción industrial. Fijaos.
[No, lo siento, pero China no está devorando
la economía norteamericana]
Pero… un momento, entonces… si los argumentos
de Trump no son los responsables de todo el
déficit comercial de Estados Unidos… ¿A
qué se debe este desequilibrio? ¿Cuales
son las auténticas razones? Atentos.
LAS VERDADERAS RAZONES
Puede que os sorprenda pero la “culpa”
del déficit comercial de Estados Unidos no
la tiene la competencia desleal de ningún
país. En este caso la culpa se queda en casa.
[Sí, es posible que dejar de lado las teorías
que hablan de malvadas técnicas chinas para
destruir Occidente, sea mucho menos apasionante…
pero… lo siento… así son las cosas]
Veréis, la culpa del agujero comercial está
en la baja tasa de ahorro que existe en los
Estados Unidos;
en la condición del dólar como moneda de
reserva, lo que hace que sea muy demandada
y tienda a estar sobrevalorada
y también con la enorme cantidad de capitales
que todos los años llegan a Estados Unidos
procedentes del extranjero… por ejemplo,
de China.
[Como vamos a ver esto es lo que explica que
Estados Unidos llevé más de 40 años con
déficit comercial sin que la economía se
resienta. ¡Más de 40 años!¡Consecutivos!
Consumiendo más de lo que produce]
Porque amigos, Trump habla siempre de la balanza
comercial… pero nunca habla de la balanza
financiera. Y ahí está la trampa.
¿UN JUEGO DE PÉRDIDA ABSOLUTA?
Existe una ley económica que el Presidente
de Estados Unidos parece no haber conocido
nunca: la balanza de pagos siempre está en
equilibrio en un sistema de tipos de cambios flotantes,
es decir, como el que se da hoy en día.
Es decir, me explico, un déficit comercial
se compensa básicamente con superávits
en la cuenta de capital o en la cuenta financiera,
que para que nos entendamos reflejan el saldo
entre los capitales que llegan al país y
los que se marchan. Vamos la pasta que entra
y la pasta que sale.
(“Un persistente superávit en la balanza
por cuenta corriente se compensa siempre con
déficit en las cuentas de capitales. Es una
de las eternas leyes económicas, como la
gravedad en la física” - Konrad Putzier,
periodista del portal The Real Deal)
Fijaos en lo que ocurre, precisamente, con
la Balanza de Pagos de Estados Unidos:
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir esto que un país
puede comprar en el extranjero lo que quiera,
sin límites? Pues… evidentemente no.
Solo podrá importar si consigue financiar
o compensar sus importaciones con capitales
procedentes del extranjero.
De no ser así, primero su divisa se despreciaría
un montón [Pura ley de la oferta y la demanda,
mucha demanda de moneda extranjera y poca
de moneda local] y luego, finalmente, las
reservas de moneda extranjera del Banco Central
se terminarían… desatándose con ello toda
una crisis cambiaria. Esto es algo que en
Latinoamérica, especialmente en Argentina,
se conoce muy, pero que muy bien.
(Pues bien, Estados Unidos es el mayor refugio
para capitales de todo el planeta. Prácticamente
la mitad del ahorro mundial se termina invirtiendo
en este país, ya sea en forma de préstamos;
de inversión extranjera directa o comprando
acciones, bonos, etcétera, etcétera.)
Precisamente es todo ese enorme flujo de capitales
lo que permite que los estadounidenses consuman
más de lo que producen y que a pesar de llevar
más de 40 años consecutivos incurriendo
en déficits comerciales el país se encuentre
prácticamente en pleno empleo, y en niveles
récord, como hemos visto , de exportaciones
y producción industrial.
Ahora ya podemos entender noticias como esta:
(“Ya sea Japón en los 80, Alemania en los
2000 o China en los últimos años, los países
que han invertido fuertemente en el mercado
inmobiliario de Nueva York también tienden
a tener un gigantesco superávit comercial
con Estados Unidos” - Konrad Putzier, periodista
del portal The Real Deal)
Es decir, sintetizando: gracias a los capitales
que llegan del extranjero los Estados Unidos
se pueden permitir consumir más de lo que
produce. Por así decirlo, además de exportar
bienes y servicios, Estados Unidos exporta
también títulos financieros.
Pero, un momento, ¿Quiere decir esto que
no se puede reducir el déficit fiscal? Para nada.
¿CÓMO REDUCIR EL DÉFICIT COMERCIAL?
Cómo veis, las cosas a veces no son tal y
como parecen ser en un primer momento.
Tener un déficit comercial no tiene porque
ser malo, al fin y al cabo el objetivo último
de la economía tiene que ser mejorar las
condiciones de vida, es decir, poder consumir
más y mejores bienes y servicios.
Pero… eso sí, un déficit comercial abultado
y continúo si supone, por un lado más riesgo…
riesgo de que los capitales dejan de fluir
hacia el país lo que le podría llevar a
sufrir una importante crisis, y por otro tienden
a favorecer el crecimiento de la deuda
[¿Un país inundado de dinero del extranjero?
Eso significa dinero abundante y barato, y
amigos ¿Quién no quiere dinero barato]
Por tanto, vayamos a la pregunta clave, ¿Cómo
puede Donald Trump lograr reducir el déficit
comercial de Estados Unidos?
Pues existen, principalmente, 3 opciones…
2 que es mejor dejar de lado y 1 muy recomendable.
(Las dos primeras serían , por un lado, ponerse
de acuerdo con la Reserva Federal para devaluar
el dólar y lograr que deje de ser la moneda
hegemónica en el mundo, así las importaciones
serían mucho más caras y nadie querría
llevar su dinero a este país; Y por otro
restringir los capitales que pueden llegar
del extranjero, por ejemplo mediante impuestos…
claro que eso… a la larga sería un desastre.)
La otra opción, la recomendable, es consumir
menos, ahorrar más y favorecer la inversión
productiva.
De esta forma se demandarían menos préstamos
del exterior y se generaría mucha más riqueza,
de tal forma que porcentualmente sobre el
PIB los déficits comerciales serían mucho
más pequeños.
Pues bien, para lograr este objetivo, frenar
el cada vez mayor agujero fiscal del gobierno
sería una idea fantástica [Pero Trump a
pesar de su discurso va en la dirección contraria]
También sería una opción fantástica permitir
que las empresas estadounidenses pudieran
ocupar los casi 6 millones de puestos de trabajo
vacantes que hoy sufre la economía norteamericana
trayendo profesionales del extranjero.
(En cambio... las políticas proteccionistas
no funcionan… primero porque el resto de
países suele responder a tus aranceles, con
lo cual se reducen las importaciones pero
también las exportaciones; y sobre todo porque
el incremento de costes que suponen los aranceles
hacen que Estados Unidos sea un país menos
atractivo para invertir…. y eso a larga
es algo malo, muy malo.)
Tal vez, amigos, la mejor prueba de que las
empresas norteamericanas necesitan estar abiertas
al mundo lo encontramos en la propia familia
Trump.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
¿Sabíais que Ivanka Trump, la hija del presidente
y asesora especial en la Casa Blanca tiene
una marca de moda, de ropa y zapatos? ¿A
que no adivinais donde fabrica sus productos?
¿Tal vez en Estados Unidos? Error, habéis
fallado… La respuesta correcta es ¡En China!
¡La mayor parte de sus productos se fabrican
en China! Y luego también en países como
Vietnam e Indonesia.
¿Será la propia Ivanka Trump cómplice de
los malvados que están atacando Estados Unidos
con sus malas artes comerciales? Ahí lo dejo.
(Precisamente, justo ahora, en julio de 2018
y tras las críticas por tantas contradicciones
y una abultada caída en sus ventas, Ivanka
Trump ha anunciado el cierre de su línea
de moda y complementos.)
Ahora si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
echanos una mano dándole a like y suscribiendote
a VisualPolitik si aun no lo habéis hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.